heute fand die deutsche islamkonferenz
mit innenminister horst seehofer staat
ja die islamkonferenz hat das ziel das
zusammenleben der deutschen und der hier
lebenden muslime zu verbessern
also eigentlich ein gutes ziel dass sie
verfolgt doch jetzt gibt es heftig
kritik kritik an der islamkonferenz
nämlich von hamed abdel-samad er bis
heute zehn jahre teil der deutschen
islamkonferenz doch jetzt hat er seinen
rücktritt so in einem facebook post
erklärt da wollen wir ihnen einmal dass
die grafik zeigen
sehr geehrter herr innenminister horst
seehofer hiermit trete ich aus der
deutschen islamkonferenz zurück als ich
vor zehn jahren in dieses forum
eingeladen wurde hatte ich die hoffnung
teil eines ehrlichen dialogs über den
islam in deutschland zu werden
nein ich mache nicht mehr mesz die ditib
standards sind loyalität zu erdogan und
zum türkischen nationalismus ja lieber
herr innenminister ich mache auch die
islamkonferenz für die politische
aufwertung von ditib und den zentralrat
der muslime verantwortlich und somit für
den aufbau von erdogan kult und die
stärkung des politischen islam
mitverantwortlich und ich halte die
unterstützung dieser vereine nicht für
veruntreuung von staatsgeldern sondern
auch für eine gefahr für die innere
sicherheit deshalb nehme ich weder an
der heutigen sitzung und noch an
zukünftigen sitzungen der islam
konferenz teil und ziehe mich endgültig
zurück wir haben sie oft gewarnt unsere
warnungen wurden nicht gehört nun tragen
sie die ganze verantwortung alleine und
haben mit updates haben hat ist mir
jetzt live zugeschaltet guten abend gut'
vielleicht können sie nochmal kurz
zusammenfassen sind ja wirklich
drastische worte die sie gerade da in
ihrem facebook post heute geschrieben
haben warum haben sie diesen post heute
verfasst und ihren rücktritt erklärt
weil ich nicht mehr mit vertreter des
politischen islam an einem tisch sitzen
will
weil ich nicht mehr teil einer komödie
sein will der staat befördert den
politischen islam schon seit mehreren
jahren man hat die muslime eingeladen um
einen teil des dialogs zu werden aber
man hat nicht normale muslime eingeladen
sondern vertreter
und ausländischen organisationen
verlängerte arm der erdogan regierung
verlängerte arm der muslimbruderschaft
organisation
man hat dadurch nicht mehr der
vitalisierung bekämpft man hat dadurch
nicht die desintegration bekämpft im
gegenteil man hat einen erdogan kult da
geschaffen und ich wollte nicht mehr
feigenblatt werden in dieser
islamkonferenz deshalb habe ich heute
meinen rücktritt meinem rücktritt
erklärt sie haben es gerade auch noch
mal gesagt auch in ihrem posteingang
kult hat man erschaffen warum sagen sie
denn dass die islamkonferenz daran
schuld hat weil nachgemessen september
hat man versucht die islamischen
organisationen sozusagen einzuladen um
teil eines dialog zu werden
die idee dahinter war dass diese
islamischen organisationen uns herrschen
sollten einfach mit radikalisierung
zurückzukehren dazu kommen dass die in
den moscheen oder die kalibrierung
bekämpfen sollten dass sie muslime
helfen teil der deutschen identität zu
werden aber genau das gegenteil ist
passiert wir haben seitdem mehr rechts
haben der dem meer religiösen
extremismus mehr diese integration und
mehr erdogan kommt wir sind das einzige
land der welt das ein erdogan kult mit
steuergeldern finanziert von einem mann
einen kunst von einem mann der eine
aggressive machtpolitik gegen den resten
betreibt der mit dschihadisten
auch sich zusammen verbunden hatte
erdogan ist mittlerweile der anführer
des politischen islam weltweit
erdogan ist mit seinem islamistischem
soll dann an mehreren kriegen
gleichzeitig beteiligt in libyen in
thüringen im irak von jetzt zwischen
armenien und aserbaidschan
er versucht seine machtposition im
mittelmeer auszudehnen und wir
unterstützen seine verlängerte arme
indem wir ihnen fördergelder geben damit
sie noch mehr von kult wir treiben und
deshalb mache ich auch die
islamkonferenz dafür verantwortlich auch
diese den politischen islam politisch
aufzuwerten und dieser machtposition zu
ermöglichen vor dem ersten september hat
kein mensch von diesem von diesen
politischen islam oder von diesen
vereinen überhaupt was gehört und ich
beschreibe das in meinem aktuellen buch
aus liebe zu deutschland
und ich warne davor was eigentlich
gerade geschieht wenn wir so
weitermachen wächst dieser monster noch
mehr und überzieht uns mit perron mit
dass integration und
erdogan und seine verlängerte arm haben
kein interesse daran dass die hier
lebenden türken teil der deutschen
realität werden im gegenteil
erdogan benutzt sie um uns zu erpressen
genauso wie er die gefühle der muslime
nach den karikaturen benutzt um uns zu
erpressen und das muss aufhören
aber wenn sich jetzt kritische stimmen
wie die ehre daraus zurückziehen ist es
nicht gerade wichtig dass auch kritische
stimmen so einer konferenz zur sprache
kommt das nicht dann eher gefährlich und
kontraproduktiv
ich bin nicht der einzige aber ich bin
seit zehn jahren dabei und ich habe
versucht so viel es geht meine themen
unterzubringen
ich wollte über radikalisierung von
jungen muslimen sprechen über
gleichberechtigung von mann und frau und
ich sprechen
ich wollte über antisemitismus unter
jugendlichen aber die islamverbände
haben immer blockiert und die
staatlichen vertreter aus bund und aus
dem lernen dann waren schüchtern und
haben nichts gemacht und am ende sind
note drei themen geblieben und das
wollten die islamverbände sie wollten
nun über imam ausbildung über
islam-unterricht und über muslimische
seelsorge eigentlich wollten sie nur
geld vom staat haben und umsatzsteuer
damit sie weiterhin erdogan kult
aufbauen damit sie weiterhin einen
orthodoxen islam einen nicht
aufgeklärten islam an den rückständigen
islam in ihrer moschee weiter verbreiten
sie haben es übrigens abgelehnt
die imam ausbildung an deutschen
universitäten zu machen weil sie dem
deutschen staat gegenüber skeptisch sind
weil sie nicht wollen dass der deutsche
staat die kontrolle behält sie wollen
selber die kontrolle behalten und
deshalb haben sie das abgelegt und ich
will nicht steigbügelhalter für den
anhänger und für die muslimbruderschaft
damit sie die imam-ausbildung key
ausmachen
ich will nicht ein feigenblatt für die
islamisten werden des staates leiber
macht sich mitverantwortlich für diese
misere und die kirchen auch die die
vereine des politischen islam über jahre
hin unterstützt und ermächtigt haben und
das muss irgendwann enden und ich will
bei diesem spiel nicht mehr mitmachen
dankeschön hamed abdel-samad für das
gespräch und ihre klaren worte vielen
dank sein geben auch mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren